[Musique]
alors que l'effet de harcèlement à
l'école semble se multiplier ces
derniers jours la vidéo de la jeune
chaîne a prise à partie par ses
camarades circulent sur les réseaux
sociaux
[Musique]
à mettre fin à leurs jours le suicide de
l'Insee présent insulté menacé
quotidiennement avait choqué bouleversé
la France entière cette semaine
devant tout le monde un décès tragique
qui a poussé un groupe de motards à se
mobiliser et à créer une association
pour rendre visite aux élèves harcelés à
la sortie du collège
une initiative qui a touché certains
parents
mobilisation incroyable de motards pour
accompagner les élèves harceler
l'initiatrice de l'action témoigne ce
soir dans TPMP
[Applaudissements]
qui est la présidente de l'association
motard solide
franchement bravo merci d'être là en
tout cas merci à vous ça vous fait très
plaisir et bravo parce que franchement
c'est une magnifique initiative c'était
la première fois que vous me dit ce
genre d'action oui habituellement c'est
plus des cortège mariage des choses
comme ça que j'organise donc quand vous
avez eu l'idée vous avez vu ce drame
vous êtes dit comme nous je peux pas
rester sans rien faire c'est ça en fait
je suis tombé j'ai été une manifestation
du dimanche je suis tombé sur la cousine
de l'Insee clavier son t-shirt hommage à
l'INSEE et donc je me suis permise parce
que je suis un peu connue sur Tik Tok
donc je lui ai dit est-ce que tu veux
que je partage l'info et elle m'a dit ce
serait génial puisque justement ça fera
du bruit et on a besoin à son
enterrement en fait des motards parce
que ses parents voulaient que ça fasse
un beau cortège donc je dis enfin je
vais je vais organiser ça avec toi et
donc on a géré en fait le truc comme ça
tout simplement c'est fou alors
elle a réagi comment
on a été la chercher c'est ce qui m'a
apporté à savoir que c'était compliqué
comme émotion en fait parce que c'était
un peu mélangé parce qu'il y avait une
des harceleurs quand même sur place
ma moto c'est la grise et elle était moi
j'étais là ben je vais filmais c'était
moi juste derrière et Maëlys était à la
sortie du collège elle voulait parler
non du tout du tout non parce que je
reste neutre en fait donc je peux pas
prendre parti et je le ferai pas et à la
justice pour ça donc et ça a été quoi sa
réaction là un sourire sourire un
spectacle clairement
et les autres élèves du collège sont
réagis comment alors c'est pour ça que
j'ai choisi les motos parce qu'en fait
ça surprend mais
en général les jeunes ils viennent vers
nous ça les attire en fait le bruit les
moteurs les grosses motos enfin ça les
attire certains sont venus faire des
photos en fait sur les motos et d'autres
bah j'ai déjà eu d'autres témoignages
pour venir en aide en fait et
dans ce même collège et intervenir pour
une petite en particulier qui a subi par
les mêmes harceleuses
qui vous a parlé le proviseur de votre
action et ce qui était content pas du
tout alors là ils étaient pour vous on
va peut-être un endroit pas ils étaient
à la grille en fait il y a la première
grille là où on est et ils étaient à
leur porte qui le proviseur je pense que
c'était le groupe on voyait pas de loin
mais ils étaient en fait tous comme ça
regroupés mais il faisait pas sortir
tout simplement alors que moi j'ai fait
l'action lors de la Marche Blanche j'ai
attendu vraiment qu'il y ait plus
personne j'avais mon fils de 7 ans donc
j'aurais pas fait de enfin voilà c'était
pas du cinéma et en fait j'ai sonné à
l'interphone pour essayer de lui parler
pour lui dire que j'avais pris la
décision de créer cette association au
proviseur
c'est que enfin voilà je suis pas à côté
non plus et donc déjà il m'ont répondu
tardivement et au final sans réponse en
fait elle m'a laissé en attente elle est
partie fichier avec la proviseur
adjointe si je me trompe pas et elle a
eu ordre de faire rentrer personne voilà
ce qu'elle m'a répondu et comment vous
allez vendre de la troisième petite
harcelée comment ça s'est passé alors à
la marche blanche j'ai fait un discours
rapide parce que je voulais pas prendre
l'ampleur et prendre au dessus des
parents donc j'ai fait vraiment rapide
en disant aux enfants qui étaient
présents avec le t-shirt blanc que s'ils
avaient besoin on était là maintenant
fallait parler il fallait plus laisser
faire et qu'il y avait le facebook
motard harcelé qui avait été créé et en
fait j'ai eu le message du soir même sur
le fait ah oui non mais c'est
hallucinant vous verrez je vous
montrerai les messages que enfin je m'en
sors plus clairement je viens de lancer
ça je pensais pas que ça allait prendre
une ampleur aussi large mais il y a
énormément de l'ampleur c'est horrible
honnêtement psychologiquement c'est
compliqué extrêmement important d'autant
plus que les enfants harcelés les les la
famille de Lindsay vous l'a dit ont eu
l'impression d'être lâché donc là Maelys
il faut la soutenir et Cyril si vous le
permettez je vais vous lire un extrait
de la lettre que l'Insee
elle dit chers parents
si vous lisez cette lettre c'est que je
suis sûrement parti je suis désolé
d'avoir fait ça mais je n'en pouvais
plus les insultent matin et soir des
moqueries des menaces
je n'en peux plus et j'ai envie d'en
finir
mais rien ne les arrêtera car malgré
tout ce qui s'est passé elle me voudront
toujours du mal pardon maman je suis
parti rejoindre papa puisque son père
est décédé elle avait 3 ans
et j'espère de tout cœur que ce que j'ai
fait aura servi à quelque chose
je pense que ce que j'ai fait va les
réjouir elle penseront qu'elles ont
gagné et arrêteront tout ça
je ne pouvais même pas me confier au
directeur car il était avec elle
il ne voulait rien en moi
donc la seule chose que je pouvais faire
était de partir faites attention à
Maëlys à ce qui pourrait lui arriver
faites attention à vous je vous aime au
revoir
c'est bouleversant et puis elle a le
courage dans sa détresse de de penser de
manière prémonitoire à Maëlys
j'ajouterai juste que la famille qui
tenait une conférence de presse à porter
plainte pour non assistance
le principal du collège contre
l'académie de Lille contre les policiers
qui ont recueilli les plinthes au début
et contre Instagram et Facebook mais moi
je vous dis il faut que ça bouge de quoi
j'ai peur c'est que ça bouge pas encore
qui se passe rien il faut que ça
se passe
en contact m'a dit exactement les mêmes
les mêmes mots elle en a parlé au
directeur et en fait il la laisse il la
laisse elle m'a même dit ils ont voulu
la pousser dans l'escalier cette
personne qui était derrière moi
justement au cortège elle a voulu la
pousser dans l'escalier la dernièrement
donc je lui ai dit tout de suite
j'allais prendre rendez-vous avec ses
parents pour agir vite quoi parce qu'on
a pris le temps en fait clairement
problème c'est que ça se passe toujours
à l'intérieur quand on a l'extérieur
nous on est un peu bloqué parce que bah
la police
comme ça se passe à l'extérieur je vais
pas intervenir c'est le sentiment
d'impunité qu'elles ont ces jeunes
filles et par ailleurs que le décès de
de l'Insee ne les ai pas chamboulé enfin
c'est à dire qu'elle continue et c'est
exactement ce qu'a dit l'Insee regarde
ce qu'elle a dit et là est-ce qu'elle
dit elle penseront qu'elles ont gagné
mais penser qu'elle a elle est
je trouve qu'elle a une maturité
incroyable dans ce qu'elle dit et ce qui
est terrible c'est qu'on se dit que ce
drame était prévisible en fait parce
qu'elle savait que il y avait rien à
faire du côté de l'école que le
directeur était avec elle comme elle le
dit donc ça met d'autant plus l'école
dans une situation délicate parce qu'ils
auraient dû anticiper cette situation
c'est moi la mairie de l'éducation avant
de parler de de d'école de de de
d'administration de de juridique tout ça
voilà de plainte etc je me dis le
directeur il est c'est quand même désolé
les mecs est-ce qu'il peut encore se
regarder dans une glace tous les matins
est-ce qu'il peut comment il peut encore
aller là-bas allez bosser faire le malin
et aller bosser et se regarder tous les
jours dans une glace et se dire
les procès les trucs bien sûr que c'est
très important parce que je veux que la
famille de l'Insee veut que la lumière
soit faite sur cette affaire et qui est
des gens qui sont les parents
d'arthologie
extrêmement émouvant je trouve dans
cette lettre c'est que en fait elle
s'est elle s'est elle s'est suicidée
pour que ça bouge en fait et ça bouge
pas c'est ça qui dingue elle s'est dit
si je ne fais pas ça il a rien se passer
donc ça commence à bouger parce que vous
vous en parlez on en parle sur TPMP etc
voilà on a des témoignages comme madame
qui fait quelque chose avec les motards
donc il se passe quelque chose
médiatiquement ça commence un petit peu
à bouger mais enfin c'est c'est
largement pas suffisant
c'est quoi ce gang de petite conne les
quatre là c'est
d'effet de masse qui est en fait
inarrêtable c'est comme un effet boule
de neige quand ça commence comme ça
c'est difficile de s'extraire du lot et
là le problème
qu'ils ont dit la dernière fois ils ont
dit à un moment problème que tu as c'est
quand ça bouge pas je vous dis la vérité
il y a des il y a des parents
on va on va on va agir bien sûr et ça va
ça va
ça va mal se passer bien sûr non mais
c'est ça mais bien sûr et après le
problème c'est c'est les mecs bien sûr
ils vont se faire justifier
non mais c'est sûr parce que tu vas
faire quoi à un moment tu le dis une
fois proviseur tu vois ta fille qui est
pas bien à un moment tu dis bon
écoute-moi bien moi ça va je vais je
vais y aller moi-même clairement et ça
va partir en cacahuète non mais c'est
sûr vous avez entièrement raison et moi
Cyril j'ai quand même une colère contre
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
mais je suis d'accord pourquoi je suis
en colère normalement il doit convoquer
mais bien sûr il y a une personne qui a
disparu il y a une famille qui qui vivra
plus jamais quand même il doit convoquer
le directeur bien sûr il aurait dû être
chez lui le lendemain
ça fait des jours que ça fait des jours
qu'on en parle sur ce plateau qu'on
arrête pas de dire qu'est-ce qu'il fait
il fait rien là
c'est le décalage entre ce petit truc 4
lignes et la lettre de l'Insee qu'on
vient de lire et je suis désolé Darmanin
on peut dire tout ce qu'on veut s'il est
peut-être dans des coups de connecte un
policier tué il va sur place moi je suis
désolé pourquoi pas peine
de plus important à faire
il y a encore des jeunes qui circulaient
aujourd'hui mais non mais c'est ça c'est
le mec qui dit non on va voir on va
saisir il fait un tweet non mais donc on
est où là
on va pas se mentir je vous le dire
c'est le seul qui travaille qu'on reste
ici ils sont là pour faire des plateaux
télé bah c'est un truc de fou et c'est
vrai il faut arrêter les mecs c'est quoi
ça et bien sûr il devrait être sur place
et il devrait faire quelque chose qui
pour moi est essentiel en fait
aujourd'hui les établissements scolaires
il faut le dire il y a pas de langue de
bois ici se protège si vous reconnaissez
qui a du harcèlement dans
l'établissement L'établissement a peur
d'être mal jugement
les mecs avant tout c'est des hommes
de famille
il y a une jeune fille qui s'est donné
bien sûr il y en a une autre qui est au
bout du rouleau il y en a encore une
autre et le mec il pense qu'à une chose
c'est moi je veux sauver
les écoles les écoles sont pas égales
face à ça parce qu'il y a des écoles
dans lesquelles il y a voilà tout un
personnel qui est qui est dévoué et qui
fait bien les choses et il y en a
malheureusement c'est de l'humain c'est
du cas par cas il y a des proviseurs qui
sont des nazes il y en a qui sont des
bons mais après c'est à l'état de faire
en sorte de mettre en place des choses
pour que le harcèlement
surtout sur un truc il a raison non mais
pas peine le ministre de l'Éducation
plus
occupés à parler de nous les mecs non
mais c'est quand même hein en plus la
suite ça va être quoi on va passer notre
vie à mettre des motards devant chaque
lycée pour rester des gamines ou des
gamins
c'est sans fin et les parents des
harceleuses enfin rappelez-vous le
message de d'une des mamans qui était
genre réjouis encore plus sadique qui
sont dans ça on a le temps de mettre 68
€ pour des mecs qui tapent sur des
casseroles exactement
en fait nous aussi normalement c'est
fait en fait on avait la police arrivée
donc on s'est dit ils ont prévenu voilà
ils ont eu peur du bruit peut-être et en
fait il a pris sa caméra elle a filmé
toutes nos plaques et donc j'ai été
dessus j'ai crié parce que je lui ai dit
non mais votre travail en fait là la
sécurité c'est votre travail et donc il
m'a mal parlé vraiment au niveau de fin
voilà bref et je lui ai dit simple
cachez vos plaques en fait j'ai déjà mes
motards caché vos plaques et on va pas
être avec eux en fait clairement et donc
j'ai vu Maëlys sortir moi j'ai caché ma
plaque on a tous caché nos plaques et en
fait à priori c'est 135 euros parce
qu'on est on a pas le droit voilà je
vous assure si vraiment on les reçoit je
tape un scandale hein moi aussi hein
je reviendrai je vous assure je
reviendrai aucun problème parce que je
me suis même engagé j'ai dit au nom de
l'association je prendrai en charge tous
les motards tous les PvP motards mais
franchement je trouvais ça honteux et 68
€ 68 euros aussi parce que bah en fait
on a pas le droit de se garer devant le
collège
70 c'est 38 je vous jure que c'est le
directeur qui a appelé la police
tout de suite je vais vous dire oui tout
ce qu'on voilà je vous jure vous allez
me dire
on reparle de de ce qui se passe
actuellement mais vous voyez dans cette
émission on le voit on marche sur la
tête sur plein de choses et c'est vrai
que même ce qui se passe actuellement
même autour de nous voyons pas ils nous
font passer pour les les les méchants
ceux qui je vais vous dire ici il y a
pas plus humain que nous et on essayait
de faire bouger les choses les autres
émissions il y a pas une émission même
sur service public qui essaie de faire
bouger les choses autant que nous mais
la ministre de la Culture elle va sur
toutes les émissions elle se balade et
nous elle nous tape dessus je vais vous
dire nous on s'en fout totalement on en
a rien à [__] d'avoir des lauriers des
honneurs juste un moment pour parler de
ce directeur et de pas peine Guy il doit
le convoquer ce directeur il doit pas il
peut pas aller tous les jours comme ça
dans son lycée dans son collège
tranquille hein et se dire bah tiens moi
je vais me faire muter comme ça après
bah je serai oublié je passerai à autre
chose non mais on est fou il y a une
gamine qui est morte qui a écrit une
lettre je peux vous dire il peut pas
rester insensible face à la lettre non
mais c'est c'est n'importe quoi la
famille on les a vu les pauvres et là ça
continue donc essayez c'est c'est vous
Gwen qui est obligé de prendre les
choses en main avec des parce que
qu'est-ce qui se passe là ça peut
dégénérer ça après il y a les pères des
trucs qui vient ça va dégénérer des
questions et que je vous dise un moment
il faut bien que ça bouge
faut bien que ça bouge parce que à un
moment il y a un père je vais vous dire
il va pas rigoler sa fille il va arriver
il va il va ça va je vous dis ça va
dégoupiller c'est sûr et certainement
ils vont tomber sur un gars un moment il
va dire moi ma fille on lui pas je
t'explique ça va pas se passer comme ça
bien sûr donc je t'explique la direction
15 ou 20 moi j'en ai rien à [__] non
mais je te le dis franchement c'est le
premier truc qui vient à l'esprit bah
oui moi j'ai déjà eu des problèmes avec
mes enfants et bon un petit début on va
dire de harcèlement ça a été très très
vite stoppé c'est-à-dire que le gosse je
suis allé voir je l'ai suspendu au
plafond et je lui ai dit c'est terminé
c'était pipi dessus le gamin donc j'ai
reçu un mail des parents en me disant
oui c'est honteux j'aurais dit il y a
pas de problème on se voit on se parle
mais ça cesse voilà c'est terminé alors
après c'est pas ce qu'il faut faire non
alors je dis pas que c'est vrai mais je
dis que c'est la première chose toutes
les mamans ici
il y a un moment donné ça prend au
tripes et oui ça peut dégénérer mais
donc le problème c'est que visiblement
ils ont tout essayé de nombreuses
ça va décider parce que désespérance
c'est que vous vous le dites tout le
temps vous dites aux enfants de parler
etc
à l'éducation nationale elle a parlé au
proviseurs
il faut lancer un appel à Madame
Brigitte Macron qui est normalement est
très très sensibilisé à ces histoires de
harcèlement provoquer le directeur il
faut qu'il arrête le ministre bouge là
on l'a invité il a refusé
le ministre de l'Éducation